the German Defense Minister on the
military airfield in the capital Niemi
in Nazaire Germany financed the
modernization of the base and German
forces stationed tier support missions
in neighboring Mali and the army of
Nazir Yellin distance I'm Viet your
country is a valuable and committed
partner in the fight against terrorism
organized crimes and illegal migration
in the region we will only be able to
overcome these challenges if we work
together
my son Bashar is one of the poorest
countries in the world it's the country
of origin and transit for West Africans
heading to Europe the army of Nazir has
been unable to contain large-scale
people smuggling which has been on the
rise in recent years see la mobility our
troops are frustrated by the lack of
transport the inability to react quickly
and bring soldiers to the places they
are needed in this huge expanse of the
Sahel where all our borders are under
threat for that reason Germany has
provided the army of Nazir with 53
offroad trucks and has also financed to
college for noncommissioned officers the
total cost 11 million euros the defence
minister also officially opened a newly
built camp for 70 German soldiers in
Niemi the Bundeswehr is here for the
long haul more and more this new airbase
in near me is becoming a hub for German
armed forces already Germany is
supporting Nazir and Mali directly and
other West African states indirectly in
their fight against terrorism